There's a girl you love
Oh, oh, oh,
there's a girl
you ca
n't forget  What's important is that we're living like this right now Come on, it's
dangerous
Eh, hey, hey, 4, ah, thank you,
60 seconds left Sender, oo-san,
then get away from
me I don't know what happened, but I'm Nobu-kun's  I can't be supportive, so I don't need it
Tears that pretend to be tough don't lie
Ahaha
boy It
was love at first sight
Please go out with me It's
about time girl I kissed
rar
This is the answer
there I
envy her  What
[music]
00:00? It's
time for punishment
[music]
Whoa
Cold
lips
[music]
Because I won't give up
Today's kiss is a letter of challenge to my girlfriend
Bright and kind and popular in the class
This  A day when a child is innocent